la minería
de aquí
[Música]
el diagnóstico suele ser el mismo para
los niños de los asentamientos de maicao
en el noreste de colombia el riesgo de
desnutrición aguda no se da sobre todo
por el déficit calórico o sea que el
niño no está consumiendo los alimentos
que puedan aportarle calorías para su
desarrollo y su crecimiento un niño
desnutrido corre el riesgo de morir si
contrae cualquier enfermedad en esta
comunidad de migrantes venezolanos
la ong 'save the children' organiza
brigadas sanitarias para detectarlas
pues queda bajo mucho peso porque
entonces que no nos comemos bien a veces
comen mucho lo había en el día
cuando no ve nada la vida en comida y no
tenemos para darle
13.65 17 años victoria tiene el peso y
el tamaño de una niña de 3 años las
secuelas pueden ser graves tienen una
desnutrición crónica toda ella no va a
recuperar la talla en comparación con un
niño de su misma edad de esta forma
también se ve representado se ve
afectado el desarrollo cerebral y por
ende va a tener más dificultades para el
aprendizaje las organizaciones
humanitarias han capacitado unas
liderezas para que identifiquen los
casos de desnutrición el ide es una de
estas mujeres del sector llamado la
pista
este es el antiguo aeropuerto de maicao
aquí había una pista de aterrizaje
la comunidad surge después que empezó la
pandemia muchos de los venezolanos
migrantes que estábamos arrendado en
distintos barrios ya no teníamos cómo
pagar
más de 2.000 familias se han asentado en
estos terrenos áridos la mayor parte son
indígenas wayúu muchos viven del
reciclaje de basura
mira el baño de esta familia
el agua llega a la pista de burro
y los niños toman agua de ahí porque la
flama no tienen con que no tienen que
comprar el agua potable para tener un
cuadro de diarrea y automáticamente
siempre va a tener su problema de
desnutrición
victoria la niña de 7 años que sufre de
desnutrición crónica vive con su abuela
y otros 12 niños la falta de métodos
anticonceptivos todas las familias son
numerosas
acá hay otra mitad es hija de la señora
hay otra mamita acá que parió ni de la
cesárea se vino de venezuela hace una
semana muchas bocas por alimentar y muy
poca comida sin genoma esto ahorita un
bocadito dos cada uno de estos va a
darle ahorita
y eso es lo que yo tengo
a la hora de la siesta estos niños
todavía no han recibido una verdadera
comida en el día
desde hace más de tres años el flujo de
migrantes venezolanos en colombia no se
ha detenido con la pandemia la frontera
estuvo cerrada durante más de un año
pero las familias huyendo de la crisis y
la miseria han seguido llegando a través
de las rutas clandestinas del desierto
de la guajira los que se quedan en
maicao a 10 kilómetros de la frontera no
tienen los medios para ir más lejos pero
esta región pobre y en crisis no tiene
nada que ofrecerles en el corazón del
barrio la pista las organizaciones
humanitarias montaron un centro de
atención
de pollo no tiene especial usted lo
puede sustituir por las modernas
en esta carpa acción contra el hambre
organiza consultas y provee medicamentos
a los niños desnutridos miles de
familias sobreviven gracias a esta ayuda
de emergencia que damos una atención
integral para que las personas puedan
recibir entonces una atención
nutricional acceso a agua segura las
transferencias monetarias e información
que se es clave también para salvar
vidas
al menos 20 niños han muerto por
desnutrición en la región durante los
últimos seis meses un balance que habría
sido peor sin la ayuda humanitaria para
el iv de los habitantes del barrio
necesitan más que todo empleo yo pido
mucho la verdad emprendimiento una
capacitación y emprendimiento hacerle
una capacitación a un papá o una mamá
que puedan trabajar
trabajar para que puedan sacar adelante
a su familia y darle una vida más digna
entretanto mientras la crisis venezolana
se agrava los asentamientos como la
pista siguen extendiéndose